moskau die hauptstadt russlands eine
millionen metropole mit zwei gesichtern
weltoffen und modern aber zugleich
streng und traditionell
wir begleiten sechs schweizer und
schweizerinnen die den mut hatten sich
im wilden osten niederzulassen
in dieser fremden geheimnisvollen welt
die unter präsident putin wieder an die
goldenen zeiten anknüpfen möchte weshalb
haben sich unsere schweizer diesen ort
ausgesucht wie heimisch fühlen sie sich
hier und mit welchen schwierigkeiten
sind sie täglich konfrontiert
traum oder albtraum abenteuer moskau
[Musik]
der oldtimer rallye club moskau lädt ein
zu einer stadtrundfahrt treffpunkt der
parkplatz vor dem hotel metropol
organisator ist eine große
versicherungsfirma die oldtimer fans
gehören durchaus zum zielpublikum für
hoteldirektor dominique integriert und
schnitzt und entsprechender ich würde
das metropol bitte dienst sprach dinge
ist natürlich wichtig ist er ideal so
wie es der gute ruf des hauses hat viele
jahre gelitten
sehr fragwürdig sogar einen spielsalon
und das haben wir nicht sofort wo die
neuen sitze das wollte mit ihrem antrag
so versucht los verdammt werden komplett
distanzieren
ein stück mitzufahren das lässt sich der
hoteldirektor nicht nehmen
eine limousine ein sowjetischer
klassiker dieses fahrzeug baujahr 1961
gehörte einst kommunistischen
parteibonzen heute darf dominique auf
dem beifahrersitz platz nehmen
dass er den kopiloten spielen muss damit
hat er allerdings nicht gerechnet
[Musik]
der stau vermeiden möchte nimmt besser
die bahn
es wird leider guggenbühl und ihr
australischer freund tieren sind auf dem
weg nach sankt petersburg
die 26 jährige hat vor kurzem ein
startup gegründet café import für die
neuen coffeeshops die überall aus dem
boden sprießen die tochter einer russin
und eines schweizers lebt erst seit zwei
jahren wieder in moskau und verspürt
aufbruchstimmung und es macht man sitzt
eine zwischenfrage sammler oder lang war
das jetzt machen wenn ich etwas
probieren
die schattenseite der selbstständigkeit
was nach honeymoon aussieht wird von
einer sekunde auf die andere wieder zur
dienstreise
ich mag
svetlana ist in moskau geboren und in
der schweiz aufgewachsen zum master
studium wechselte sie nach london wo sie
erste erfahrungen im rohstoffhandel
sammelte ihre mehrsprachigkeit ist ein
großes plus in diesem business
eine echte kosmopolit ihn also doch wo
fühlt sie sich am meisten zu hause wenn
ich jetzt entscheiden
der schweizer gewann das ist super den
trägt und dass ich selbst sehe ich sehr
dass ich sehr schön alles ist der summe
ein rechtsstaat
vielleicht ist jetzt nicht ganz extremes
ganz neues startup zu machen
aber ja ich glaube dass lediglich viel
einfacher
vom bahnhof geht es direkt zu einem
coffee shop im zentrum von sankt
petersburg
die shops kaufen die grünen kaffeebohnen
und rüsten sie selbst um sie dann aus
hauseigenen café weiterzuverkaufen
es wird lang und tieren promoten ihr
produkt in der anfangsphase am liebsten
persönlich das ist wichtig für vertrauen
wir sind den sankt petersburg bleiben
vorerst 100 in der northwest coffee
company meinen lang in der café operiert
bis sie angefangen hat alles offen der
zweite bezirk zu ihnen aufbaut also
erhöht wenn wir jetzt sollten wir im
nächsten monat den pos amlacher sie war
das so dass sie schon mal in die hand
und sichtbar kaffee sorten auswählen
[Musik]
zurück in moskau heute ist ein
besonderer tag für bauunternehmer roland
lay seine beiden söhne sind zu besuch
als er beschloss sein glück in russland
zu versuchen ging seine ehe in der
schweiz in die brüche den kontakt zu den
söhnen dominique und claudio hatte
arbeit gehalten hier vor allem ihr jedes
mal wenn sie auf moskaus mit ist
natürlich hilfe die schweiz also hilfe
der schweiz als sie moskau sichere
emotional die freiheit das festprogramm
zimmer gestellt sind
minibagger seiner freunde mit novo sehr
schmales russland sind und sehr schwarz
mosca sind möchte eine natürliche
linderung bringen
erste station ist die aussichtsplattform
vor der moskauer universität roland
macht den touristenführer er kennt ja
praktisch jeden stein kennelbach an ihre
zeit im luschniki damit die golde und
das ist eben die kirche aufbauen und hin
und reiste kennen so dominique kennt
sich ebenfalls gut aus die stadt ja wie
stück heimat wurden ich bin in jena
statt
man darf nicht in die kamera und jetzt
muss man in die kamera sagen dominiques
freunde sind sich für einen derben
scherz nicht zu schade
spaß muss sein sogar ein erinnerungsfoto
mit einer fremden schönheit liegt drin
und das obwohl die freundin gleich
daneben steht ganz umsonst gibt's das
natürlich nicht aber in die touristen
falle tappt roland nicht normal oder ja
niemals nie
sonntagmorgen bei dorothea kolde die
menschenrechtsbeauftragte wartet auf die
handwerker dorothea hat vor kurzem neue
fenster einsetzen lassen
aber es gibt noch probleme da oben gibt
es viel schimmel
das ist es lich und auch schlecht für
die gesundheit ich hoffe dass ich jetzt
im winter kein durchzug mehr habe die
handwerker lassen auf sich warten
[Musik]
jawohl
sie haben die häuser verwechselt und
sind anderswo hin gefahren
schließlich klappt dann aber doch dass
mit den neuen fenstern war ein
ziemliches wagnis und ist aus einer
laune heraus entstanden
sie zogen um die häuser um ihre fenster
zu verkaufen
niemand wollte was dann klingelten sie
bei mir und fragten können sie uns einen
tee machen
ich weiß nicht was mit mir los war aber
ich sagte gut kommt rein beim tee blieb
es aber nicht die handwerker boten
dorothea gleich neue fenster für
umgerechnet 4000 franken an und dorothea
sagte spontan zu
[Applaus]
wie konnte ich nur diese leute rein
lassen und dann noch einen vertrag
unterschreiben und sofort bezahlen ja
wir gingen zusammen zur bank um das geld
zu holen ich bin verrückt
solche dinge kann ihn in einer stadt wie
moskau auch ins auge gehen
aber vielleicht hat er nach 23 jahren
russland schon das richtige gespür
die schweizer botschaft hier ist auch
der sitz des swiss business hub
stellvertretende leiterin willi
berchtold ihr job schweizer unternehmen
zu beraten die in russland geschäftlich
aktiv werden wollen
doch die zeiten für investitionen sind
schlecht pharma und medtech produkten
ist das maschinenbau und konsumgüter und
fragen jenatv luxus gibt es ist
natürlich so dass diese mit politische
krise und problemlos landwirtschaftliche
kann sehr viel schwierigeres worte für
russland liche fehlen hier fuß fassen
schlecht vorraum finanzierung ist es
schwierig wurde und geht wenn maschinen
etwa 1 million forschte das klappt habe
oder irgendwie aus der verkäufer zweite
produktes zahlen sammler das heißt durch
kredit und die kredit sie wollen dann
sehr sehr gut und das macht für viele
schweizer filmer schwierig
juli macht den job seit einem halben
jahr interimsweise bis der neue chef
anfängt sie und das siebenköpfige team
warten gespannt darauf ob der neue auch
frische ideen mitbringt wie man das
schweizer engagement in russland
ankurbeln könnte
was verspricht man sich von der neuen
besetzung macht ist die große heute ist
es soweit
lawrence witmer der neue swiss-chef
kommt mit seiner familie aus zürich an
sehnsüchtig erwartet von seinen alten
gasteltern bei denen er schon als
student gewohnt hat das problem der flug
ist verspätet
[Musik]
dies bedeute hals zu
doch dann alles gut
als sich der kohle
wir sind jetzt platzt der heime
losgegangen verabschiedet haben die
ältere verabschiedet am bahnhof mit
freiem auge mit mutter und den
schwiegereltern auch weil mit dem metro
sind am flughafen
jetzt flogen sie nach wo soll hier
belegt woraufhin und da ist begrüßte die
sich alles sich wie chrom schön sehr
berührende momente als erstes braucht
lorenz eine neue russische telefonkarte
ich bin schon lieber
ehefrau caroline nimmt den start in ihr
neues leben gelassen
nach klasse
auf motorrädern der kleinen tröpfchen
mutter bringt das eine option
[Musik]
in sankt petersburg wird alles für die
große café degustation vorbereitet das
publikum jung und interessiert
der stil sehr westlich eine hippie szene
vor ds mit langen und gleich ihr
verkaufstalent beweisen muss
[Musik]
chefin irina teils mit lamas café
passion
wir suchen eine gewisse süße im café und
eine schöne ausgewogenheit das ist die
hauptsache sehr warme atmosphäre freuen
flensburg aus seeth ekholt von pater
hatte ich aber sehr wurden vor der lügt
wenn man natürlich in moskau andré große
restaurant hat ihr wort kaffee agierte
denis schon sehr viel schwieriger als
hoch vor allem ansprache vor allem als
junge frau ich glaube mir hilft aber
dass er immer für zeller dass meine
eltern so langes und der name der hand
also dass man jetzt als buch startup
sind sondern dass man auch mit der
schweiz durch witzige augusta immer sehr
hoch auch sie immer als qualitätsmerkmal
und darum glaube ich dass man dazu auch
hier hilft dir viel machen oder älter im
lokal der wichtigste mann heute ist was
er ist der größte und entscheidet
letztlich welche neue sorte gekauft wird
am ende findet er unter den vielen
angeboten tatsächlich einen favoriten
michael j während jetzt 66 kilo das ist
natürlich der tisch die grafen dich sie
aber die beste und beides natürlich
gefallen
zurück nach moskau
hoteldirektor dominique ist unterwegs
als co pilot am oldtimer rallye
russische straßenkarten lesen in der
zwölf millionen metropole ist nicht
einfach
[Musik]
so lange dauert der sonntägliche
oldtimer ausflug allerdings nicht
dominique muss zurück ins hotel
roland hat seine reisegruppe aufs wasser
geführt seine söhne sind ohne ihren
vater groß geworden
gemeinsam mit zeit ist nie alltäglich
sondern immer ein event
auf das schweizer wm finalspiel topspiel
wir machen faire miteinander das ist
dennis augustin alltag wo man hätte
eigentlich aber so dass wenn du nicht so
cm labs
der alltag nimmt also dass sich
freundschaft und vater sohn beziehung
ist doch nicht so ausgeprägt denke
komplex kritik übten die schwierige
frage aber so bin ich denke es ist
wunderschön hier so eine enge beziehung
gehabt sich und jeden tag danach
verständlichen wir haben mit der sonne
eigentlich nicht die bezirke und denke
dass ich war es liegt kunden dieses abo
sender sich an bord muss
eigentlich positiv und negativ also ist
sehr speziell
nachher plaudert der bauunternehmer noch
ein bisschen aus dem nähkästchen
jetzt hat maria laach
ich schon mal so dort stand ein institut
geste und den widerruf war vor 50 jahren
da an die kamera gefangen bevor 12 yo
und den ist ein abbau der auftraggeber
gelbe karte im rigg stellt sich das mehr
als zehn jahre lang stillstand in
isselburg ist aber wabe und svp mia
einziger baum überhaupt unterliegt das
bauwesen in russlands eigenen gesetzen
zum stichwort korruption äußert sich
holland allerdings nur sehr
zurückhaltend wie es mit aufträgen
dürfte an kann ich nicht zeigen will
mehrere lieder in den bereichen tätig
sind
aber mein körper vor ort egal ob das
immer dieses geld muss fließen damit man
auch wissen auf sekunden
das moskauer stadtviertel karczewski
rund 15 kilometer außerhalb vom zentrum
lawrence witmer und seine familie sind
bei der wohnung der gasteltern
angekommen
[Musik]
hier hat der ökonomie einst sein ausland
studienjahr verbracht
der stopp kopper hat mich im vital signs
detail zu sehen in dem 70 seelen ort und
weg der heime wenig stark mit verbunden
wäre
lorenz und seine familie fühlen sich
hier sehr wohl
trotz bescheidener verhältnisse soll es
den schweizer gästen an nichts fehlen
bei einem besuch in freunde mit
juristisch mit wunderschöne sache
es gehört auch nicht so ja das ist halt
das ist doch wirkliche aber das ist
tatsächlich auf die beziehung zu seinen
gasteltern ist eng geblieben
seine zeit hier hat lorenz geprägt dass
ich das zimmer wo nicht warten new york
unter dass ich mich bei tital sich
stenzel oder auf der reise index
standard das ist weit von vitalis sieht
oder eingeschlafen ist dahinter ist sie
auch noch ein leeres aufgabe machen sie
sich sehr gut
[Musik]
wieder in sankt petersburg nach einem
erfolgreichen arbeitstag bleibt für die
beiden kaffee unternehmers mit land
kämen noch ein bisschen freizeit die
chance für einen gemütlichen bummel
durch die berühmte zarenstadt speziell
russische geschichte hat mit dem ganzen
zauber tun
es ist sehr berührend wenn wir die sache
so sieht und dass das eben bis heute ein
großer teil unserer kultur ist die
architektouren russland ist der hammer
vor allem wenn man aus australien kommt
unsere ältesten gebäude sind nicht mal
100 jahre alt unbeschreiblich
svitlana ist in einer erfolgreichen
unternehmer familie aufgewachsen
doch dabei stets bodenständig geblieben
so hat sich das paar heute anstatt in
einem luxushotel lieber in einem
gemütlichen hostel einquartiert in der
gemeinschaftsküche hat jemand für alle
gekocht zeit um die junge liebe zu
genießen tieren ist wegen svitlana nach
russland gezogen was baurechtlich bohren
wird sie aber im moment ist alles extrem
bedacht
doch die mühe lohnt sich die
jungunternehmer haben bereits kunden im
ganzen land immer mit dem gleichen ziel
vor augen expansion und es gibt noch
viele coffeeshops zu erobern
[Musik]
ihre beziehung ist erst ein gutes jahr
alt aber sie haben bereits über
familienplanung gesprochen
ein thema das sicher erst aktuell wird
wenn das geschäft gut genug läuft
[Musik]
in rjasan sind roland und seine söhne
nach drei stunden autofahrt endlich auf
der datscha angekommen
der türsteher auf vier beinen heißt
cherry ein amerikanischer akita rolands
freundin katja ist natürlich auch da sie
hat schließlich heute geburtstag
die beiden haben sich hier in der gegend
kennen gelernt als holland in der nähe
eine baustelle zu betreuen hatte seit
sechs jahren sind sie ein paar
die rollenverteilung ist klar zumindest
heute
[Gelächter]
es ist in russland nichts ungewöhnliches
dass ältere männer jüngere freundinnen
haben 25 jahre russland haben roland
geprägt aber ein paar schweizer mütter
links sind geblieben
[Gelächter]
in europa aber natürlich war die
europäsche gemerkt dass auch richtig
russischen stil hat gott
zurück in die hauptstadt
im saal des hotels metropol findet der
rallye tag mit einer großen gala seinen
krönenden abschluss für dominik ist es
wichtig dass die gehobene moskauer
schicht hier wieder einkehrt alles muss
stimmen
[Musik]
um die reputation wenig sie zunichte
gemacht worden ist von metropolis mit
reputation mit hersteller die moskowiter
gesellschaft ist laut metro provinz
rotes durch sie und entsprechend muss
mit dass wieder kommuniziert das ist
heute das fremde das entsprechende neue
service stil da ist gastfreundschaft wo
effektiv auf jedem niveau sehr hohe
qualität gewährleistet wird alles sind
zufrieden
ein erfolg für den direktor und ein
weiterer schritt in die richtige
richtung feierabend auch für julie
bechtold die 41 jährige bernerin
interessierte sich schon als studentin
für russische literatur und hat hier die
liebe ihres lebens gefunden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
juli spricht fließend russisch doch die
beiden unterhalten sich auf deutsch für
ehemann andré war es selbstverständlich
sprache zu lernen kursen gut war dass
liebe weil das ich je kennengelernt habe
hatte ich eine idee okay sie kommt aus
der deutschsprachigen schweiz
dann wäre es gut dass ich nicht nur
englisch und französisch mit den
verwahrten rede und mit den freunden
sondern dass sich deutsch lernen und
dann habe ich deutsch gelernt und nach
einem jahr war ich schon mit dem
deutschen gut gesprochen habe
wir haben uns gut verständlich da komme
ich zum silvester in der schweiz
und dann denke ich das war wirklich eine
total andere sprache das war für mich
ein bisschen sollen schocken denn so
muss ich auch sagen eine demotivierung
mir die tweets würde würde für einige
mag weil aber seit mitte der 80er
einfach per und alle die schweiz nicht
verdrängen
ein grund zurück zu gehen wäre höchstens
präsident putin seine macht politik
wirft schon die frage auf wo russland
hinsteuert es geht hier gefahrgut
politische situation nicht möglich
aber die schweizer staatsbürgerschaft
dabei ist die stadt ihr vater seine
familie und in russland bestehen sollte
und dass die schweiz nicht und das ist
ein riesiges fragezeichen
die überlegung zurückzukehren ist etwas
womit sich auch bauunternehmer roland
lay beschäftigen muss doch heute abend
sind seine söhne hier und freundin katja
hat geburtstag
deshalb wird ordentlich gefeiert
roland gibt in gastgeber und ist einfach
nur glücklich
für die beiden ist der vater wie ein
bester freund und eine helfende hand bei
allen wichtigen fragen
ich glaube als roland seine kinder
eingeladen hat haben sie ihre eigenen
pläne über den haufen geworfen um die
hier zu kommen sie sind ja nicht zum
ersten mal da sie hat nie abgelehnt
dieser abend wird sicher sehr familiär
und schön dass claudio und dominique in
der schweiz leben birgt für roland ein
ganz praktisches problem wer soll seine
firma später einmal übernehmen
wie sich herausstellt eine schwierige
familienangelegenheit
für beide generationen
die nation noch einmal nach volk mache
mir schon gedanken und die der familie
gecaj will der domenico eigentlich
wieder ihre branche gelernt hätte und
tätig ist er möchte nicht nach russland
keine geständnisse für die tiroler sind
so einfach
und wieder einmal durchmachen eines
sicher ebenso wie weißrussland gelten
und sich an jeder kurve kann ich ja
schlecht dieser wege ist denke ich ein
vierteljahrhundert lang kann man da sind
einfach abhaken und säge da ist jetzt
vergessen soll und nur jetzt hat ja ganz
okay
die ganze zeit und er verbrachte ich
lebe das land also sich nicht als ihnen
gern da bist es wäre es ja nicht machen
die wirkung der kontaktpflege mit dem
land das ist der user haben die leistung
vollbrachte pewal die jahre
sicherheit daneben und das hitzfeld aber
so ist leider
[Musik]
zurück in der hauptstadt es ist
freitagabend aber noch nicht feierabend
für dorothea sie macht sich bereits
nochmals in die stadt zu gehen die 53
jährige genferin hat sich erst vor
kurzem von ihrem mann getrennt
wir sind noch alle seine bücher
er liest sehr viel wir haben zusammen
sehr viel gelesen er ist jetzt weg aber
sein zimmer ist noch all das ist erst
vor kurzem geschehen
aber so ist das leben ich will jetzt
nicht im detail darüber reden
dieses zumeist jetzt für freunde das ist
sehr praktisch ein zusätzliches zimmer
zu haben
ein adieu an tochter sophie dem
wichtigsten menschen in ihrem leben
die sowjetischen musikerinnen bis heute
an die bauzeit der moskauer metro
sie ist meist das schnellste und beste
verkehrsmittel um ans ziel zu kommen
um die sieben millionen passagiere sind
hier täglich unterwegs
die stationen liegen bis zu 80 meter
tief dorothea liebt metro fahren dichte
stress kennt sie nicht
[Musik]
das stört mich nicht ich merke es kaum
ich versinke da oft in meinen gedanken
aber ich beobachte auch gerne menschen
kein problem
jetzt fahren wir zur station belaruskali
ins italienische kulturzentrum
ich versuche dort italienisch zu lernen
seit april
ich bin noch ziemlich am anfang
dass sie ihren freitagabend dafür opfern
muss macht ihr nichts aus
[Musik]
freitagabend ist sogar gut so kann man
ideal das wochenende beginnen ein
kompletter wechsel
drei weitere frauen besuchen mit
dorothea den italienischkurs lehrer
alles anders sagt seine sprache sei bei
den russinnen äußerst beliebt trotzdem
eine schweizerin die in russland
italienisch lernt ist das nicht
eigenartig ich verwechsle alles ein
bisschen am anfang des italienisch
kurses kamen sogar japanische wörter
raus ich hatte davor bereits fünf jahre
japanisch gelernt
jetzt geht es besser ich höre ja oft
italienisch in der schweizer botschaft
[Musik]
aber es geht dorothea hier nicht nur um
die sprache sondern auch um ablenkung in
einem lebensabschnitt der nicht immer
einfach ist
ich hatte in letzter zeit viele probleme
bei der arbeit aber eben auch in der
familie und ich brauchte unbedingt etwas
was mich dort ein wenig raus bringt
darum habe ich dann diesen kurs
angefangen es hätte auch sonst
irgendetwas sein können aber sprachen
mag ich schon sehr
[Musik]
morgenstimmung auf der datscha
nach dem frühstück heißt es für roland
söhne bald schon wieder abschied nehmen
das ist schmerzhaft für alle beteiligten
wie immer aber sie kennen es nicht
anders
roland weiß dass das ende der ehe und
die trennung von den kindern damals vor
allem für den jüngeren sohn nicht leicht
waren
wer heute den schritt heute beweisen er
wieso ich habe gott und die
verschiedenen die grünen sie aber ich
denke das ganze gesehen war nicht im
leben gelernt und war nicht für den
anderen horizonte profis wieder machen
und ist als user vorderachse ist
natürlich auch wenn man schwere 20 uhr
durch aber trotzdem ich denke höher so
wieder machen
zurück in der stadt juli bechtold muss
wegen des umzugs in die wohnung der
schwiegereltern nun oft hin und her
die gelegenheit um sich endlich für die
leihfahrräder zu registrieren
in moskau gibt es das system noch nicht
so lange und wie immer erweist sich die
moderne technik als tückisch
[Musik]
sydney
de vries elektronisch zum ersten mal
geschafft
in zukunft kann juli sogar mit dem
fahrrad zur botschaft fahren
in der neuen wohnung stehen noch viele
kisten herum
juli muss alles alleine machen ihr mann
andré ist beruflich unterwegs ihre
tochter vera bei der großmutter in der
schweiz
zeit für einen kleinen schwatz
hallo
es wäre demnach besteht momentan ist
momentan noch bestellt ist und da ist ja
noch liebe stets 2700 kilometer distanz
sind auch mit skype nicht so leicht zu
überwinden
[Musik]
lorenz wittmanns seine familie haben die
erste nacht hinter sich nun erkunden sie
die gegend zwölf millionen einwohner
leben derzeit in der metropole
das ist fast eineinhalb mal so viel wie
in der gesamten schweiz
doch lorenz ist zuversichtlich dass er
in der großstadt zurechtkommt
natürlich vom landes wachsen im lothar
nicht in der schweiz und das sind schon
andere dimensionen das ist schon so ja
aber das macht ja offen und groß dass es
pulsiert in der nähe des bahnhofs kinos
werden sie wohnen
deshalb müssen sie herausfinden wo es
hier was zu kaufen gibt nach dem ersten
rundgang ist sich lorenz sicher
verhungern werden sie kaum
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich dass ich dennoch die
marktprofis vor seiner wohnung war war
ich beziehe an die juli
und hätte man denken können auch egal
was es da hält einkaufsmöglichkeiten und
sich sehr schön die vor jahren also ein
paar jahren überhaupt nicht mehr mit
einem statischen morgen sondern
sowjetische machten sich wunderschön ist
[Musik]
für die kinder gibt es einiges zu
entdecken
und auch das angebot ist überzeugend
also heutzutage kommt mir alles über den
moskaus wirklich sehr vielseitig und
qualität schauen ein sehr sehr gut
also ich finde das vorurteil womöglich
zum teil hat russland in moskau mit
einem monatlichen durchschnittslohn von
umgerechnet 700 franken können sich
jedoch viele russen diese qualität nicht
leisten
als getränk russischen spezialitäten das
im sommer ist sehr erfrischend deshalb
wahrscheinlich ist das was jetzt völlig
neu ist dass mit der familie glaube aber
ich glaube moskauer stadtgericht la paz
wartet auch mit familie und ich bin
sicherer klingt beiden erfolgen weil ich
mache weiter der nächsten vier jahre
aber es wird sich also vorher das ist
klar das familienabenteuer ist auf vier
jahre angelegt ehefrau caroline ist
ebenfalls gut gewappnet
sie hat bereits in mehreren
osteuropäischen ländern gelebt und
spricht auch russisch
es können jeder aber gleich mit
vielleicht die beste einstellung die man
haben kann wenn man irgendwo neu anfängt
in der nächsten folge baubegehung in der
neuen schweizer botschaft rolands
herzensangelegenheit doch ihm läuft die
zeit davon
außerdem überraschung für svitlana ihr
alter tanzpartner matt ist zu besuch für
die kaffee händlerin eine willkommene
abwechslung und neue wohnung aber keine
möbel um nicht auf dem boden zu schlafen
muss lorenz improvisieren